I want to put my conversation with
Ivanka Trump into the broader economic
context the big domestic policy question
for 2020 is this how to keep the Trump
economy growing now the establishment
state media's campaign to talk America
into a recession seems to be working at
least among the elite last week we saw
the biggest drop in economic confidence
among CEOs for seven years
oh there's only one problem nobody told
the American people look at this
headline in Axios consumers are spending
in fact all the indications are that
this will be a blockbuster holiday
season see what that headline says
holiday sales poised to jump on US job
market boom that is the key the
president was right jobs jobs jobs it is
all about jobs if people are working
more and earning more they'll keep
spending and that's what keeps the
economy moving consumer spending is two
thirds of our economy thanks to the
Trump pro-growth policy agenda Americans
are working and earning at historic
levels but we can't just sit back and
hope it goes on seems to me there are
four big things that can be done to keep
it moving forward first the Fed can keep
cutting interest rates everyone agrees
they made a massive mistake putting them
up at the end of last year dampening the
incredible growth we were seeing then
they've been trying to make up for it
since but there's a limit to what they
can do so second get the trade deals
done everyone focuses on Trump's trade
war with China which by the way he
didn't start
he's just the first president who's
actually fighting back but what about
Trump's trade piece you've got the u.s.
MCA sitting there waiting for Congress
to approve it but on top of that you've
got deals with South Korea Japan India
the EU if all these get done in the next
few months that is a massive boost to
our economy the third thing cut taxes I
like the idea of a payroll tax cut early
next year for workers and employers pass
it in the Senate and then let's see if
Nancy Pelosi really thinks it's smart
politics to block a tax cut for American
workers and intellect
year the president wins either way but
the fourth thing that can be done to
keep the economy growing is exactly what
if a hunker Trump is doing just look at
this piece of data at the start of
president Trump's term we had 1.9
million more unemployed than we had job
openings and look at the turnaround now
we have 1.2 million more job openings
than unemployed of course that is great
news in one way but as andy paz de
president Trump's first nominee for
labor sector II put it in a brilliant
piece in The Wall Street Journal this
week a shortage of skilled workers is
now holding the economy back that's why
Ivanka Trump's work on this is so
important